Ryan cost Dunder Mifflin hundreds of
thousands of dollars Michael Ryan David
I don't care if Ryan murdered his entire
family he is like a son to me
what
oh nothing
Jim's been looking at me kind of a lot
all week
I would be creeped out by it but it's
nothing compared to the way Michael
looks at me
this next award goes somebody really
lights up the office
somebody who I think a lot of us cannot
keep
checking out
the hottest in the office award goes to
Ryan the temp
now
[Applause]
you sexy thing
here you go
hanging in a hundred and a house
there you go there you go what am I
gonna do with the award
laughs
nothing I I don't know what I'm gonna do
that's the least of my concerns right
now I am in this game yesterday
in prison you are somebody's [ __ ]
oh and you you my friend would be the
bell of the ball don't drop the soap
don't drop the soap Michael please
Bryant
[Music]
hey yeah there he is there he is he's
back and he's with a beard
he has facial hair look at him oh
growing up and no place to go hello Mr
Sonny Crockett
I'm tubs
okay should we get started oh yeah let's
get started because uh yes because it
was a very serious business yeah and um
exactly this is a business meeting
I love that that's right that's right
fire guys
you weren't here for that here for what
how big he is look at you you are so
mature and old and little man now you're
like our little little old man boy
Michael everybody
um bearded man boy let me say something
I know I used to be a temp here but now
everything is different I'd like your
respect I am your boss now you're gonna
have to treat me the same way you treat
a Jan oh wow so that's a little cakey I
don't swing that way okay
I think Ryan is a gay Crush off enough
okay this is inappropriate and it stops
right now
do you understand
yes
everybody come on settle down let's get
serious here
um Ryan has a very special important
presentation to do which we'll be doing
in the conference room in 10 minutes
perfect sound good okay
all right
yeah Ryan snapped at me but there was
this twinkle in his eye that I picked up
on which said dude we're friends I'm
doing this for appearances I am the big
boss now and I have to seem like an ogre
but you know me and you trust me and we
like each other and we'll always be
friends
and I would never take you for granted
in a million years
and I miss you man and I love you
his words
how's my favorite Branch doing
all right
things were an all-time sad here but
then I got an email from Ryan that he
was coming back to town and I called the
temp agency and I told them I will pay
you any amount just give me Ryan Howard
give him to me I want him I need him and
you got to go t I did did you get that
after you helped me move and you saw
mine yes goatee
hey hey shaved I did why
hey Ryan look Brothers
yep
[Music]
why you just Dive Right In
you know around age 12 I just started
going for it
[Music]
what what happened
I fell off the toilet
I'm caught between the toilet and the
wall
what do you need no not you someone else
get paid I think Pam's gonna want to
come into the men's room you're Ryan
oh he needs to lift me
and it needs to clean me up a little bit
bring a wet towel
Brian is uh dead no he's not Dad I just
saw him no ladies and gentlemen may I
have your attention please I know that a
lot of you were very angry with Ryan
because he is the reason we all have to
come in tomorrow however I swear to God
if any of you hurts him in any way
emotionally or taunts him or makes fun
of his height or his half beard okay he
thanks Mike yeah
oh Ryan I need a girlfriend so bad
Michael let me go let me go Michael all
right
Mr Scott who's this other woman
Ryan who you refer to here as just as
hot as Jan but in a different way not a
woman just a cool great looking best
friend aren't we trying to determine
whether Michael and Jan were engaged in
a romantic Affair not Michael in this
Ryan person
all right all right well I would
definitely have sex with Ryan
thanks
because he is going to own his own
business
my heart says no your heart is a
wonderful thing Michael but it makes
some terrible decisions that's true yes
that's true because it's gone down the
wrong path many many times Jan Ryan yes
why don't you give me your contact
information to start with okay what's
your cell
uh Larissa Halpert
what's her address 117 on Bergen Street
hello
hey Ryan
this is Michael Jackson
calling from wonderland
you mean Neverland
what
you talking to me
you talking to me
Raging Bull but you
oh I want that footage I want it I need
it
oh I have to get back to work I have
lots of work oh oh check this out come
here there he is Mr temp having lunch by
the car
let us play with him The Surreal Earth
seven new messages first new message all
right
hi Rob Hussein
next message hey Ryan this is girlfriend
Michael are you okay
I'm just worried about my friend Ryan
whoa video iPod
oh wow jeez somebody really got carried
away with this Spirit of Christmas
that was me I got carried away with the
spirit it wasn't there a 20 limit on the
gift
this is 400 bucks
you don't know that yeah you left the
price tag off I did yeah why oh shoot
wow okay well who cares doesn't matter
what I spent what matters is that
Christmas is fun right
year after year I catch a lot of flack
on this particular award because year
after year I present this award to a guy
instead of a girl hottest in the office
goes to Danny
cordray Danny could not be here tonight
how do I feel about not winning hottest
in the office this year
um I'm very relieved how do you how do
you judge something what is his criteria
even it's
it's so subjective will you marry me no
that would be hot I would pay to see
that will you marry me holly no only one
that I was kind of worried about
all right